presented by
no one oh man even with kevin here we
can't get since nights
listen some tradition should never end
and even though ernie's not here
we're still doing the neato stat of the
night well i hope he heard his back
i know uh he'll be missing ernie yeah
ernie uh
your regular voice ernie thank you guys
i appreciate it
i'm coming back from the capitol bernie
you know what
i saw you ernie listen oh you already
that ain't right that's not right that
is not right those aren't his friends
those are not his folks those are not
ernie's folk
but since this is a new year i think we
should do new year's resolutions for the
stat of the night oh really
and yeah i want to hear each one of your
new year's resolution let's start with
shaq what's your new year's resolution
well i want to communicate with people
that i love a little bit more
so be expecting text from me
because i i haven't talked to you in
what two years i haven't talked to kenny
since the last time we left
and i i haven't talked to chuck at all
so hey hey
you ever talked to him in two years he's
a good friend man i don't have friends
like you
you know kenny you know what i'm not
gonna get so emotional when you when you
talk crazy
because last year i'd have knocked your
ass out
this year i'm gonna just you know i'm
gonna just stay cool calm and collected
wow
so chuck stick the sticks and throw me
break my bone but words will never hurt
me
that's so beautiful kenny your new
year's resolution um
i've started i'm writing a lot more yeah
doing a lot more writing instead of give
us a demonstration
no i'm writing i'm actually i'm writing
a book not a tell-all book but a book
so i'm writing it about it i've been
saying that for years i've been saying
that for like lobbyists
i've actually thought is it a dr seuss
book or is it a
book this is a scholarly book let me
tell you something you write a tell-all
book you ain't gonna live to collect the
money
you know 20 years of my secrets
that's what they that's the name of my
book 20 years of charles
secretary what did you tell them chuck
hey you
you might write the book but you ain't
going to spend all the money
charles we want to hear your new year's
resolution but we know it already
you said you're going to try coffee you
know two years i'm trying to drink two
cups of coffee a day
why it's healthy for you that's the who
told you that was helpful
from american uh i met it was an
american journal of medicine
same people told you this no he said he
had a list it said nine reasons you
should drink coffee
uh diabetes stroke uh parkinson's and
things like that he had nine different
diseases
that uh coffee okay so i've been trying
to drink coffee and i'm a learning
process right now
oh you know what well this is your lucky
day because we have michael
from switch yard is here he's a barista
and he has
put together some concoctions some
blends so you can find something that
feels right too
you taste it as well switch yards what's
your quick yard so hold away before you
go chuck
michael where should he start let's
start on the left side
okay far left we're gonna start with
that just taste that and then i'll tell
you what's in it
take it to the head
this black coffee man it's just straight
black straight black oh no
i mean i like a lot of things straight
back right that's straight black that's
the healthiest coffee right there
yeah it just tastes like cream if you
want to be healthy right yeah if you
want to be healthy i want it to taste
good too that guy's a comment i'd like
to
chuck one more swallow go ahead straight
black okay
what's this one nope he's gonna tell you
after you taste it
swallow this is pretty
good okay that's less healthy you like
it sugar and milk in it but
but but a lot of people like that sugar
and milk you want me to
you want me to do the stuff to be
healthy stuff don't taste good
i'd eat vegetables if that was the case
you don't eat vegetables
i like the sugar in milk you don't eat
any vegetables i eat rice from corn and
potatoes
that's not vegetables in my house they
are oh my gosh
this dude here all right chuck let's go
let's go to that last one
try that last one that looks like soda
it does
[Music]
this is the nastiest thing what is this
here
that's gas station cold brew right there
that's a cold brew
from a gas station hold on hold on
jeremy
it don't taste good hold on jeremy roll
the video i'm about to show you what it
really is
i got you this he's messing with you
eric says face eric eric johnson ernie's
son
wanted me to try a cold brew but this is
the best it can taste
you can put cream and uh sugar in it it
would taste so what's the
what's the okay let's say you said black
coffee is the healthiest
what's the one thing i can put in there
that don't make it
honey bad like this will be unhealthy
i think you put a little bit of cream
okay and a little bit of sugar you just
got to do it in moderation
yeah that's the that's that second one
right there is gonna be healthy and
the best combo right there but it's not
as healthy as black coffee that's true
yeah but you got one more we got one
more we have we have one we have
one more chuck we got one last
concoction this is the switch yards
special okay okay okay and i'm and i'm
actually gonna i'm gonna
do it right here oh that looks like hold
on i hope you put some henny in that
thing
that looks like motor oil all right
let's hand it kenny
we just made you wear that sixers jacket
on purpose i did it coffee tastes better
coffee tastes better when you
taste that one boy please have some
alcohol in it
that won't be healthy tell me man that
looks like motor oil
[Laughter]
yo chuck you can't be just eating
drinking things people just give you
should like that yeah you should like
that's got some sauce in it
it's got some sauce in it yeah you like
that what's it like what's in there
what's in there michael it's the special
sauce you got to come to switch yards
for more of that but
kind of good though isn't it i like this
what kind of alcohol is in there
hey man stop being a snitch that's right
i can smell it from here
could it be redmond vodka it's red my
vodka it's got red mine in it yeah
you see him switch out real quick it got
real good all of a sudden didn't it
special sauce huh i'm glad this is the
end of the night
oh man we'll be saying some crazy stuff
oh no
he does that yeah hey michael from
switch arts thanks for bringing us out
the coffee
thanks for bringing the special sauce
yeah man yeah he found his brew
listen guys let me just tell you
something it was a pleasure being here
tonight i want to
thank you for letting me hang out ernie
thank you for letting me hold your seat
anytime welcome anytime not any time but
you can come
okay i'll sneak in every once in a while
you know what special sauce means in the
hood
what's that i'm asking you oh yeah yeah
that's that yeah
for kenny charles and of course ernie
johnson i'm kevin frazier good night
from atlanta and
hey happy new year everybody put a
little special sauce in your car
that black coffee straight up